i nomi a volte sono come degli scrigni
custodiscono dei segreti dimenticati per
esempio il paese in cui ci troviamo
proprio ora che si chiama al lancio di
intenti che non è nient'altro che la
forma contratta di wingardium leviosa il
nostro viaggio inizia proprio da qui da
questa villa imperiale semi maledetta
nonché l'unica villa imperiale
dell'emisfero boreale co superato
l'ingresso di questa villa imperiale ci
troviamo quello che il locus amoenus di
questo di questo luogo di questo scrigno
ed ecco qui un pezzo forte di
quell'epoca un ter e konko scores
comunemente chiamato telecomando con dei
piccoli segnali di luce faceva capire
quando era arrivato il momento di
cambiare canale perché il programma era
troppo trash o perché non era adatto
alla visione dei minori senza ombra di
dubbio questo è l'oggetto più richiesto
ma anche più diffuso all'epoca stiamo
parlando all'incirca del 78 79 avanti
dopo cristo un'epoca in cui le chiamate
non avvenivano per ovvie ragioni ma
c'era il trinchillo corò room un oggetto
molto strano ma che aveva una funzione
specifica ma stava infatti molleggiare
con questo andamento ciclico ma anche
buttarlo contro i muri per sentire nei
paraggi con un'antenna che ovviamente
adesso non c'è più ma vi assicuro
arrivava fino a 10 chilometri orari per
trovare l'anima gemella o più
comunemente qualcuno con cui estra
allacciare da un letto all'altro ma la
cosa fondamentale di questa villa si
trova proprio qui all'esterno ma
partiamo da questo tavolo questo tavolo
in marmo romano un marmo che veniva
spesso dolcemente livellato con della
caccia e pepe
o un'amatriciana con tutti quei piatti
tipici della cucina romana e quindi mi
immagino questi romani che dopo aver
costruito il tavolo cliccavano
dolcemente questo tavolo assaporando i
sapori più reconditi della loro cucina
ma non vi ho portato di certo qui fuori
per parlare di enogastronomia questo che
vedete qui davanti vi può sembrare un
oggetto inanimato un oggetto che senza
mente non serve a nulla ma vi fermo
subito perché qui davanti
signore e signori avete un esempio per
storico forse bionico di arco ruskin
kiros cus comunemente chiamata arpa
proseguiamo con quello che è chiamato in
antichità pianu sull venus almeno un
piano proprio perché in antichità che
costruiva queste ville imperiali
chiedeva sempre al proprietario
quanti pieni vuoi il proprietario a quel
punto rispondeva uno almeno
da lì la locuzione latina piano salme
e proprio in questo piccolo
ricongiungimento astrale tra le stanze
questo tono di conciliazione familiare
troviamo quelli che ai tempi erano
elementi super tecnologici
partiamo con un città circa cifo no mix
comunemente chiamato citofono
pensate che componendo questa sequenza
asterisco cancelletto asterisco
cancelletto ai tempi regalavano
addirittura una suoneria polifonica
questa suoneria veniva poi ricondotta
automaticamente a quello che è un filo
room a strazio score hus comunemente
chiamato wifi una scala veramente ripida
che ci porta all'ultimo piano il
mansarda rics man sardo room comunemente
chiamata mansarda o anche soffitta era
tipico in quegli anni siamo attorno al
34 38 dopo è avanti cristo portare nelle
ville imperiali come dono ai proprietari
degli ammassi di persone comunemente
chiamati cori
infatti proprio qui davanti si
posizionava il coro si parla di circa
150 197 meno 47 persone che si ponevano
proprio qui davanti e voi direte e qual
è quindi il nesso questi che vedete non
sono dei comuni fornendo questi sono gli
antenati dei sì dj impianti che si
suonano in discoteca e vedete qui
proprio con questi pomelli veniva
regolata l'intensità i bit si parlava
già di techno dance di musica house
ovviamente a livello primordiale sarà
sicuramente una musica migliore di
quella di adesso
prima di salutarvi ci tenevo a portare
alla luce una testimonianza di colui che
ha vissuto l'epopea l'evoluzione negli
anni nei secoli di questa villa
sto parlando del custode dice marcus a
menus comunemente chiamato gianmarco
zagato che cosa ha significato per luogo
circostante l'importanza culturale di
questa villa spaccato che questa casa
qui è tanto sono passate tante persone
da qui sotto sopra avanti indietro io
curo tutto qua questa colonna qui l'ho
messa io questo pavimento l'erba qui
intorno fosse sempre in coro è venuta
tanta gente che voleva comprarla ma io
non lavoro e voglio salutarvi così con
questa porta che si chiude su un passato
che non c'è più ma si apre su un
presente che esiste su un futuro che
verrà
vi chiedo quindi di farmi sapere qui
sotto nei commenti
che cosa che è piaciuto che cosa che ha
colpito di più di questa villa imperiale
vi ricordo inoltre di iscrivervi se non
l'avete ancora fatto proprio al mio
canale e di seguimi su tutti gli altri
social a menis comunemente chiamati i
social network in sagra tik tok ma anche
facebook ma anche youtube ma anche
quelli che verranno e che ancora non
solo vi saluto ma vi ripeto che questo
non è un addio
ci vediamo presto marino coulisse maric
ansys comunemente chiamati mariners
ed è proprio qui a lanzo di intendi che
troviamo partiamo proprio da questa
colonna in cartongesso
partiamo proprio da se non sbaglio in
cartongesso da eduardo possa occupare il
dare to ha concesso autentico stoico ma
è questo l'oggetto più richiesto del 77
avanti ma dopo cristo un trentini norma
il radar che comunicava con questa
piccola antenna che adesso non si apre
più ma vi assicuro arrivava fino a 10 km
ora può non tirare dare bastonate al
muro a 10 chilometri orari per trovare
l'anima gemella
un marmo seguito cliccavano dolci misti
do fa sol la cami asterisco cancelletto
vi rimane calata una suoneria